a grim discovery is raising new
questions about the safety of climbers
on Mount Everest four bodies were found
yesterday inside a tent at a camp near
the summit camphor is nearly 3 thousand
feet from the top of the world's highest
mountain American doctor Rowland
Yearwood is among four other climbers
who died last weekend this year's death
toll on the mountain has risen to 10
vadoma duthiers of our streaming network
cbsn shows us why it may be getting more
dangerous Vlad good morning good morning
we still don't know who these four
climbers were or how exactly they died
they were found by Sherpas were trying
to recover the body of another man who
died over the weekend with the news of
these four additional deaths Mount
Everest has well surpassed its average
death toll for the year it's a deadly
season on Mount Everest after two deaths
earlier this year for additional
climbers died over the weekend including
Vladimir strepa
of Slovakia Brenton bishop was near the
summit when he stopped to join the
rescue efforts Vladimir was up there
really unsupported trying to climb
without oxygen and I mean things didn't
work out well for him when a team of
Sherpas set out to recover Stratis body
they stumbled across another discovery
for unidentified bodies in a tent the
deaths come as Everest is seeing more
climbers than ever
the Nepalese tourism department has
issued a record 371 climbing permits for
foreigners
experts say overcrowding could make
scaling Everest even more dangerous
Bishop also believes some climbers are
failing to take necessary precautions
there are a lot of people that aren't
qualified to be on the mountain right I
mean I see I can't believe that they're
not more people that are killed up high
because I see a lot of unqualified
people that didn't trained and do their
due diligence the latest deaths mean
Everest has claimed 10 lives this
climbing season when typically there are
only six more people died yesterday but
no good reason climber Adrian Ballinger
is documenting his push to Everest his
summit on social media earlier today on
snapchat he reacted to the recent deaths
on the mountain and a lot more people
who are meant to be with quote-unquote
guides making good decisions
we're up high on the mountain where they
shouldn't be in brutal weather the four
bodies remain at Camp for some twenty
six thousand feet up the mountain
recovery teams will work to bring them
to a lower camp where they can be
airlifted by helicopter and hopefully
identified Charlie glad things